with Donald Trump and Ben Carson
dominating the GOP race with talk of
giant walls and end of days the chances
of a libertarian insurgency are looking
slimmer by the hour so what about the
Democrats sure they're known as big
spenders with an affinity for
one-size-fits-all regulation and the
borderline creepy reverence for the
power of the federal government
commercial thing that we all belong to
but they say their hands off on social
issues and sometimes even call
themselves civil libertarians and that
at least has the word libertarian in it
right we watched the first debate with
wide eyes and open minds and picked out
the best and worst of the night these
are the three best and three worst
moments of the first Democratic
presidential debate the third best
moment the candidates have tried
marijuana as have pretty much everybody
in this room others have not does that
influence coming in third on our list of
the best moments of the debate was the
dense discussion of marijuana
legalization just as quickly as public
opinion shifted these polls have
suddenly become very chill on the
subject if you were a Nevada resident
how would I suspect I would vote yes
because I am seeing in this country too
many lives being destroyed of the
nonviolent offenses but one candidate
seemed a bit confused Hillary Clinton
won't say what she thinks about federal
prohibition are you ready to take a
position tonight no but she knows she
doesn't like its effects we have got to
stop imprisoning people who use
marijuana the third worst moment let's
begin and listen by understanding the
Bernie Sanders has a d-minus voting
record from the NRA on the flip side was
the Dems almost uniformly uninformed
view of gun control it's time to stand
up and pass comprehensive gun safety
legislation as a nation everybody else
has to be accountable but not the gun
manufacturers and we need to stand up
and say
not that we're not gonna let it come
only one candidate recognized that you
don't have to be a DC politician to have
the right to bear arms for
self-protection there are people at high
levels in this government who have
bodyguards 24 hours a day seven days a
week
the average American does not have that
and deserves the right to be able to
protect their family the second test we
talked about Syria you're talking about
a quagmire in a quagmire most of the
candidates didn't hold back from
criticizing the interventionist foreign
policy that defines the Bush
administration and continued on through
the Obama years I would not be so quick
to pull for a military tool I believe
that a no-fly zone actually secretary
would be a mistake
you have to enforce no-fly zones it's
not about Benghazi per se me it is the
inevitability of something like Benghazi
occurring in the way that we intervene
in Libya of course others were less than
apologetic we did not put one single
American soldier on the ground in Libya
and I'll say this American citizens did
lose their lives in Benghazi unless you
believe the United States there is
always the potential for danger and risk
the second worst moment tonight I want
to talk not about my emails but about
what the American people want from the
next President Clinton's fellow
candidates weren't shy about criticizing
her role in botched middle-eastern
foreign policy initiatives but some were
quick to jump to her defense when the
topic turned to her email problems that
the American people are sick and tired
of hearing about your Damn emails
the crowd may have left the unapologetic
posture but a standing ovation doesn't
change the fact that Clinton is still
under federal investigation for
compromising classified information
while serving as Secretary of State
there's nothing partisan about that I
have been as transparent as I know to be
the best moment of the first Democratic
presidential when you shut down the NSA
surveillance or course unlike Hillary
Clinton Edward Snowden intentionally
made classified information public as a
whistleblower calling attention to the
unconstitutional surveillance by the NSA
a rousing defense of Snowden and civil
liberties from a couple of the
candidates provided the night's best
moments Edward Snowden is he a traitor
or a hero no I would bring him home the
American government was acting illegally
that's what the federal courts have said
and once again Clinton found herself on
the wrong side of the debate he broke
the laws of the United States he could
have been a whistleblower he could have
gotten all of the protections of being a
whistleblower he could have raised all
the issues that he has raised and I
think there would have been a positive
response to that and the worst moment of
the first Democratic presidential debate
first we're going to explain with
democratic socialism is the candidates
never once mentioned the national debt
and seem to believe that soaking the
rich for tax money will fund all their
big ideas the parade of ill-conceived
federal initiatives trotted out by the
candidates provided the worst moments of
the night you don't cut Social Security
you expand it investing in
infrastructure and clean energy we are
going to have medical and family paid
lead my plan would enable anyone to go
to a public college or university
tuition free what do you think we're the
best and worst moments of the night tell
us in the comments and don't forget to
subscribe to Reason TV
you